people who eat hard-boiled eggs for
weight loss it works you know why
because you're literally nauseous for
the entire rest of the day basically #
EG is the idea that eggs suddenly and
unexpectedly start to taste like too
eggy when you overeat them but I think
the reason that this is such a
phenomenon right now in 20123 is that a
lot of people got into eating eggs
during the pandemic we were working from
home and avocado toast was all the rage
and we had a lot more time to cook a
breakfast at home instead of just like
grabbing a latte and bagel on our way to
the office so we are eating a lot more
eggs so I would say that the primary
reason for a lot of people's egg ick is
just sensory fatigue and this can easily
be mitigated by mixing up your protein
sources or switching up how you prepare
your eggs and if we're lucky after a
little cool off period the eggi will go
away hope that helps folks get cracken